good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast
it is a ambiguous Tuesday here in New
York City what's good Claude hey Jax I'm
good
I'm literally woke up four seconds ago
usually I give myself thirty minutes
before the toast but um I just couldn't
do it I was having crazy dreams all
night because I finished Outer Banks and
it's kind of like a crazy show and I was
having dreams like I was there you know
we just we just had to restart this
podcast because Claudia like
accidentally spoiled all of Outer Banks
and we were like we should start again
um I'm so glad he finished it and I'm so
glad that you're like in the Outer Banks
world I feel like that's the best place
to be right now ya know I have so many
thoughts and really funny is that been
joined me for like the last four
episodes and he was really into it and
he's like he was like these kids are
gonna be stars stars okay and he went to
find them on Instagram and John B
follows me and Ben on Instagram and been
like gee I'm Tim was like great show
like so good and he was responded like
instantly and then John me dm's me to
stop responded to one of my stories
about how nobody respects hopes
scholarship that's so true and so real
we are gonna do a whole Outer Banks
recap but we want to wait until more
people watch it so I don't know but
maybe we should do it today because like
Wednesday Thursday Friday starts to get
all booked up you know cuz we have tear
toasters and Real Housewives and
Kardashians let's just do it today and
then people can listen when they're
ready that is such a good point like the
beginning of the week is always late and
then I feel so rushed on Wednesday
Thursday Friday shows yeah I totally
agree we even had wanted to do that
likes teeny lexicon episode but I guess
I don't we'll have to wait till next
Tuesday we're just so bigger Monday or
Monday yes or Monday I mean so glad that
you watch it I am looking forward to
recapping it I started this new book
last night that um we came highly
recommended to me by like people that I
know not just toasters so it's really
like heavy so that's where I'm at I'm in
like in the 90s in Idaho I'm like living
on a Mormon farm sure it sounds like Han
wives tale wives hand tale what's a cult
and why Handmaid's Tale I never watched
that so I don't know I don't know me
neither but I
it's about like Amish people no it's
like it's like a utopian world
oh I never watched it it looks like it
has like it just delivers Pitts every
episode yeah I agree with that um I have
two really quick things to say if I may
mm-hmm
one is a question for you are you
feeling triggered at all by my headband
I am like when you came on I obviously
didn't want to bring you down because
clearly you like put time and thought
into your headband but it's triggering
okay because the only reason I'm wearing
a headband is I'm filming a day in the
life log check he did one last week and
I'm copying her because I asked him a
few things to do today that I think
might be good flawed content and I don't
know I just was like sitting on the vlog
waiting for you to send me the zoom link
of looking like a beast
and I needed like something to film and
I actually like the headband and I just
knew that it would trigger you so I just
wanted to apologize in advance oh thank
you that's so considerate I wasn't gonna
say anything because you know how I feel
and sometimes I even wear that style of
had been I'm just a hypocrite but I'm
just like a self-loathing headband
wearer and it's not all headbands I just
wanna make that clear it's like this
certain style of like knotted at the top
like baby headband I'm just gonna say I
feel like you don't really hate the
headband you hate someone we know who
wears it a lot that's what I'll say no
it's like it's a whole slew of things
that I dislike about it the second thing
I want to say really quickly is an
apology to anyone watching on YouTube I
am doing my laundry today so I didn't
make my bed I thought it would be dumb
to like make my bed and then strip the
sheets and I was just not in the mood so
Jackie's bed like looks all hotel and I
look like like a crack den but I just
wanted to put it out there that there's
a reason oh interesting I guess how will
be me tomorrow because I'm gonna strip
after I wake up tomorrow
I love strip it could have got the pod I
didn't even think about how that could
affect the pod these are the things you
have to think about when you have a home
studio interesting okay I guess I could
angle my camera a little different but
like my bed is cute so sorry I also have
one more thing to say I discovered
something on tick-tock that I think it's
important please share Chris Cuomo's
daughter
I want to say her name is Bella she's so
pretty and they're like all holed up in
their house and Chris keeps like getting
in the chick talks and she's talking a
lot about how both her parents have
coronavirus and it's a premium follow me
Mia Wow that's actually a great segue
into our first story so I feel a so
maybe without further ado we should just
jump right in
sure fast five stories that you need to
know before you wake up and take a bite
out of your morning toast okay um a
little family Cuomo drum it's not drama
it's cute actually Christina Cuomo says
that she has a wait list of women for
her brother-in-law Governor Andrew Cuomo
if you found yourself questioned on New
York Governor Andrew Cuomo get in line
according to his sister-in-law Christina
Cuomo she's got a whole wait list of
women who have reached out to her about
setting up a date with the governor when
the pandemic ends she said I'm really
proud of Andrew I have a lot of incoming
calls and texts from friends so I've put
together a wait list of women who want
to go out with him which is so cute that
is so funny um so like I'm glad eligible
women are reaching out I'm just sad that
it's not us I don't know a few weeks ago
I would have put myself on the list but
today I wouldn't why I'm just done yeah
but like wouldn't you rather be
quarantined in Governor Cuomo's Alabama
I mean Albany Palace no no I don't even
care I don't even care where I am like
it's still the same thing as happening
um I wonder who these women are like
being so thirsty like honestly I admire
the hoods but like it takes balls to
like ask the governor sister-in-law that
like your hulusi acquainted with like if
you could set her up if she could set
you up with the governor the governor
yeah I feel like it's like the Real
Housewives of New York you know I feel
like it's like Ramona Sonja
Dorinda that's the crew you know and
also that's who I can see himself that's
who I could see him with yeah I think it
would be great for like the state if he
somehow you know ended up with a Real
Housewife of New York I think it would
be great for like interstate
communication I feel like honestly might
be Sonja because he liked Sandra Lee two
shots of vodka you know and I feel like
Sonia has that energy yeah I think
Ramona like I just I think it's just he
wouldn't get her I don't think they
would vibe
I think jorinda I think they're too
similar I think he likes a fun girl and
I think durin does like a little too
heavy in some ways not emotionally what
about LuAnn no I I see what you're
saying like if Andrew Cuomo was
hypothetically to fall in love with one
of the Real Housewives which keep in
mind would absolutely never happen it
would definitely be Sonia like she has
the pedigree that he needs as mayor but
she's the fun-loving girl that everyone
knows and loves and she is a small-time
celebrity and I think he's looking for
someone like famous but not more famous
than him yeah I don't think keep in mind
I think he would definitely be like a
supportive husband if his wife were
super famous yeah I think for a long
time Sandra Lee was more famous than him
like he literally like it's just popping
off right now until then he was just
like the governor and everyone was like
always blaming him for the MTA so true
like he went from being like the most
thankless job like nobody wants to be
mayor of New York because there's always
problems in New York and there's no way
to really define whose fault they are
governor I'm sorry governor and there's
no way like with all the MTA problems
and there's just like a lot of issues
that a lot of New Yorkers face and
there's no way to really pinpoint who's
fault it actually is there's just like a
structural organizational systemic
problem with the government in New York
like it's no one particular person's
fault but of course you blame the person
at the top and that's when Andrew
governor Governor Andrew Cuomo for the
last like ten years and now he's finally
getting his comeuppance and he deserves
it just like he was always this like
faceless guy where it's like Governor
Cuomo who's our Governor Cuomo and now
we're putting a face we're putting a
face to the name and it's not
bad-looking no not at all did you used
to get confused between Governor Cuomo
and Senator Schumer cuz they're both
like celebrities no I didn't but they're
just like our New York politician guys I
used to get them confused because like
Senator Schumer is related to Amy
Schumer and he's always being blamed for
stuff and Governor Cuomo is like
celebrity
and he's also always being there oh so
morose they're so different like
Governor Cuomo was not a celebrity and
then it turns out he's also a Kennedy
like shit's crazy you know yes I thought
you were just gonna say shits Creek
that's how crazy like that show has
become engrained in my mind I know I'm
so excited to catch up on the last
season I've been like saving it I might
even I might watch it in ten years even
I'm just like saving it yeah I watched
the second to last season like on my own
time and it was really lovely to like
always have it there for me I'm
definitely gonna wait until it's on
Netflix cuz I don't even know where I
could watch it right now
yeah I have the pop TV app like I could
I could binge it right now I tried one
season watching it week to week and it
just didn't have the same specialness as
watching it all together like most
things don't I've never watched shits
Creek week to week and there are certain
shows that I'm obsessed with that I
could never imagine having waited week
to week friends 30-minute episodes with
commercials 22 minutes Outer Banks yeah
other banks the OB nooks
next up Madison Pruett gathers Bachelor
contestants for a tick tock video and
throw shade at Kelly Flanagan did you
see this I saw the video and I saw the
comment I I'm trying to separate the two
so Maddie put gathered some of her
friends from her season they did that
make up challenge passing the brush to
one another video that's been going
viral is really cute she was joined by
Tammy Deandra Yara Kelsie McKenna um and
they made one of these videos and she
captioned it batch girls get ready
quarantine style hashtag Tik Tok covers
hashtag slay hashtag girl power
hashtag bachelor to the tune of I could
take a man I want to but lucky for you I
don't want to someone commented where's
Kelly obviously a [ __ ] starting comment
because like where is Natasha where's
Hannah Ann where's plenty of people and
she said Madison commented back with rx
um so you know I was actually a really
big champion of Kelly I mean of of
Maddie I really liked her I thought she
handled herself with a lot
grace would I call you a really big
champion of hers that's an exaggeration
but I was on her actually no it was I
know I I was going back and forth but I
just remembered liking Maddie in the
beginning and thinking she was like a
nice girl with like pure intentions and
then she came up on my furry page and
everything changed yeah I I didn't like
totally I like this channel this style
of video I happen to see it right after
I saw the other one of the bachelor
girls the ones from re season plus and I
understand I just like love those girls
and that's just the video for me yeah
Maddie's tick tock is just so thirsty
and there are a lot of girls on tick
tock from this most recent season and it
just it says so much about them and you
can immediately know what their
intentions were from going on The
Bachelor like Hannah and is on it and
like to be honest she can't dance and
she's just like hanging with her friends
and she's really cute and she's putting
our terrible content but she's just
having fun and that makes me feel like
she had pure intentions but like McKenna
has been on tick tock since the day she
went about sure like churning out dances
turning out followers like that's we've
always said like she went on there for
one reason and the tick tock is just
proof of that
Mady is giving me the mic can abide like
she's been coming up on my for you page
ever since the season started airing
just like basketball glam that's her
like it's just it's too much
yeah I'm not I'm not taking it so much
like she's just not the girl that I
thought she was I think still thing like
she's cool she's in fluency but I
thought I thought it was more accidental
and it just seems a little more
intentional that's the perfect word like
when you're watching The Bachelor it's
always fun to root for a girl who like
really is just there like her friend
signed her up and she accidentally fell
into you know being America's Sweetheart
it's very rare but it does happen and
that's what I thought that he was for
sure and she's genuinely nothing of the
sort
no she's genuinely nothing I'm sort it's
interesting to see her friends from the
show I guess like who's really missing
of our faves Kelsey was in the video
yeah I guess just Kelly Natasha and
Hanna Ann would be the most prominent
ones missing yeah all of the Final Four
yeah I mean it's always so weird when
you watch the show and then you find out
afterwards like who was friends like
what the cliques wear because that
doesn't really
throughout in the show they're like not
interested in like the girls only drama
but I think it's fascinating and it says
a lot of like a lot about the person
that you either like or don't like like
who they were friends with yeah
definitely
also Maddie was on Kaitlyn Bristowe spod
cast and I saw in the toasters right
before we started recording that there
was like some tea that was spilled um
including Maddie saying that like Peters
been texting her and then like when her
and Peter were trying to make it work
like she knew that he was talking to
Kelly so it's just like all really messy
so messy and to be honest like at the
end of the day all these girls they got
what they wanted out of bachelor nation
that's just Fame because there was no
way any of them were ever gonna end up
with Peter like he's so emotionally
immature the more I see of him like on
tik-tok and after batch or just like he
is the definition he is a walking n ot s
nothing of the sort
like he's just the worst so like I hate
even saying bad things about the girls
who went on a season because they were
robbed of a potential chance at love
because nope like he's just so messy
I don't know I'm like I just got like I
feel like I go all the way to one end
and then I'm like oh he's not that bad
like what he's just hanging with Kelly
now being low-key like that's just what
that's what he wanted was a relationship
I don't know whose fault it was that
everything went south I need to talk to
this natural about it like now that we
have some perspective and like
everyone's in quarantine so it's like
everyone's influence your dreams can't
really even come true right now I don't
know where the chips fell I think some
good advice would be you know something
one of my favorite um inspirational
icons one said Amanda Bynes sometimes
you just need to let the chips fall
where they may
that's what we'll do base okay are you
ready for a next story cuz it is a
little is news it's actually really
crazy um Richard Branson his entire
company is built on like tourism travel
etc it's really suffering and he has
turned into his Caribbean island to help
boost his virgin Empire so here's the
team it's really sad like his business
is suffering but Richard Branson's
Virgin Group which operates airlines
hotels and cruises and is therefore
especially exposed to the collapse of
travel during the pandemic is now
fighting for its
the billionaire founder told employees
he would offer his personal private
Caribbean island as collateral in an
attempt to raise money to keep the
business the business is afloat Branson
has asked the UK government for a loan
but the Brits have been reluctant noting
that Branson hasn't paid taxes in the UK
since he moved to his Island in 2006
overnight the Virgin Australia airline
entered voluntary bankruptcy an
administration but Branson says it's not
the end so he's trying to figure out a
way but I think if he you know didn't
have this Island who'd be paying taxes
to the proper country but now no country
like is feeling inclined to bail him out
because he doesn't pay taxes
wait that's like a low-key fact I never
knew that Richard Branson doesn't pay
taxes like that's very interesting well
he pays taxes to his Island or that he
owns so he pays the taxes tunes I'm not
sure I've actually always wondered that
like if you live on an island do you
have to pay taxes this is so interesting
and actually really really sad because I
mean I'm not even like a virgin'
customer but like he's really um like
well respected and well regarded as like
this icon and this beacon of like
business and travel and like tbg looks
up to him so much and like I just can't
believe like this is what's gonna take
out like one of the most powerful
businessmen in the world well he's not
gonna let it and now he's like telling
his employees that he's putting up his
Island as collateral so that he could
probably get a loan to keep the
businesses afloat but I just thought
that tax piece was really interesting
yeah but I feel like of all the
industries that are gonna come back when
these things slow down like Travel will
be the last yeah yeah because like we
will be able to travel at last and also
I think people are gonna be really
hesitant which just makes me so sad like
for the whole industry and just like to
think about how long that's gonna take
until we get to that place right because
like obviously Richard Branson relies on
like tourism but like so many hotels on
on small islands like their entire
economy is based on travel and tourism
so that's actually what's sad here like
not the billionaire no no but it's it's
the whole industry and I think he'll
figure out he has this sweet island um
speaking of islands I watched like a
really crazy um I don't want to like
conspiracy theory video yes
that's been going around uh cuz a lot of
people had sent it to me and asked me my
thoughts and I hadn't heard of it it was
called out of shout at shadows and it
was very much like empty you know like
Hollywood is a big child pedophilia ring
and there was just there's a few new
things that I hadn't heard of um but
everyone's been watching this video and
if you look at the comments and like
Lady Gaga's Instagram it's like all
about like blowing up her spot because
they mentioned her in this video is like
being satanic um but watch a video for
yourself because I don't want to like
speak on it out of turn I didn't see it
but I did see like the official Church
of Satanism responded to like an
official claim that Lady Gaga worships
Satan and they were like if you knew
anything about Satanism and you watch a
video like you would know that none of
that includes worshiping Satan like
they've just totally debunked the rumor
officially so I heard that before I had
ever heard of this video I'm like what
is Lady Gaga got messed up with the
Church of Satan I was like it just
seemed like nonsense
but if you care about this stuff at all
I would just say watch the video I think
it's interesting some of it was kind of
boring to me um but some of its
interesting so that's and they keeps
getting Tina out on YouTube right it
keeps getting taken down on YouTube like
but it has like millions of views every
time it goes up like so many different
people are posting it it's like they
really don't want you to see it do you
think our video today it's gonna get
taken down for talking about it that
would be crazy that would be crazy
that we'll know soon but now that we
mention it I feel like they can you know
yeah right it's like you have to say it
yeah okay we'll see
oh speaking of it's a great segue into
our next story Ryan Murphy's Hollywood
trailer exposes the sleazy history of
the movie industry so the trailer for
Ryan Murphy's new show on Netflix just
came out it's called Hollywood it's
about a prostitution ring run out of the
gas station naked pool parties held by
prominent directors shocking racism in
the casting of major motion pictures if
any of these scenarios tickle you tickle
your fancy dive headfirst into the
trailer released Monday for Ryan
Murphy's Hollywood a dark look at young
actors and aspiring filmmakers trying to
make it in trying to make it big in the
post-world War two error
era the seven parts Netflix series which
debuts May first takes us back to the
bad
days when gay actors had to live in the
closet casting directors deliberately
chose white actors to play ethnic roles
rather than risk losing precious
distribution in select portions of the
US and the best way to get ahead in your
career was to assume the supine position
and collect a fee when climax had been
achieved wait that sounds really good
mm-hmm I saw the trailer like going
around yesterday and like I'm excited to
watch it that looks crazy I can't
believe he's going into all that yeah
like who the [ __ ] would want to put
themselves in that makes you a target
like there's so many conspiracy theories
about like celebrities who mysteriously
died like weird times because they were
like aware and talking about like the
the corruption in Hollywood and I just
feel like if something happens to Ryan
Murphy like I'm drawing a line yeah the
show liberally mixes fictional
characters with real-life legends so I'm
sure they'll go in and out of like you
know alluding to actual real people but
yeah it's more so the story that sounds
really good I wish it was out now hello
I need something to watch I mean they
first is so soon in Oh time oh this
really is the first because yesterday's
birthday did you smoke pot yesterday I
did not did you know I can't smoke pot
I've been thinking though like in
quarantine like now would be the time to
take up pot as like a hobby because it's
like relaxing I guess but I don't feel
like it works like that for me like I'm
just paranoid I feel like if I was ever
to smoke pot like now would be a good as
good a time as any I just don't have any
and I'm not interested in acquiring some
I'm totally did it did the I smoke pot
bell yeah oh my god I mean he said he's
just going out for a walk with his
friends but he came back and his eyes
were all puffy but you know and I didn't
reprimand him because it's his birthday
even though he is a little young I
figured you know the kids are gonna do
what the kids want I'd rather him do it
in the house he's 21 like he's an adult
now can I just say like Amy put Amy
Poehler's saying why do you want some
because if you're gonna drink I'd rather
you do it as a house was actually like a
very smart motherly move yes you know
teenagers are gonna drink regardless
like it's better or that they're under
any Poehler's knows where she can like
see and control them but they were like
15 and then thinking like knowing first
well they weren't interested in alcohol
at all so then them her giving it to
them it's like oh what's this
and then them thinking that it's like
semi okay to be drinking alcohol at this
age like it's just a bad road to go down
that's definitely true but you know when
I have kids if they're gonna drink I'd
rather they do it in those oh my god I
don't know about that I mean like yeah I
guess I make sense but like I can't even
think about it
okay it no fifth and final fifth and
final story is a little is and sports
news what were you gonna say no I was
just gonna say that if you think 15 is
like so young but in the Outer Banks the
kids were 16 and they were like drinking
and doing drugs yeah but also when
you're 15 and somebody tells you they
love you you're gonna believe them that
is so true and when you're 15 feeling
like there's nothing to figure out
sometimes
in life you'll go through through things
greater than dating the boy I didn't
know it at 15 this microphone makes me
feel like I'm in my house like with my
studio that like recording a single yeah
it's cool it's pretty cool okay our
fifth and final story is a-rod and JLo
are retaining JPMorgan to raise money
for a Mets bid a rod and JLo are trying
to buy a piece of the Mets yep this is
fabulous so listen to the deets cuz it's
like not that simple retired baseball
star a ride in his fianc a recording
artist and actor JLo have retained
JPMorgan Chase to raise capital for a
possible but possible bid on the New
York Mets people familiar with the
matter said the superstar couple is
working with managing director Eric
men'll the bank's co-head of North
American media Investment Banking said
the people who were granted anonymity
because the matter is private none of
them are responding to requests uh the
team is valued at 2.6 billion dollars
JLo and a Rods combined networks is
seven hundred million dollars so they
wouldn't be buying the whole team
because some of it just went up for sale
but they would have they're gonna have
to raise money to buy the team
so explain like they raise money and
then once they buy the team the team
starts generating wealth and then that
wealth goes into JLo's pockets and the
people who helped raise the money I
guess I'm not entirely sure I'm not
really like you know so well versed on
sports and the ownership but isn't it
kind of weird that a-rod is like a
famous Yankee and he would be trying to
buy the Mets like I know he doesn't have
to try and buy the Yankees they are the
most expensive franchise in the country
that I know from my husband but like he
could just buy like the Houston Astros
like it's a little close to home yeah
but I think one their New Yorkers into
like it's an I don't think it's about
that at a certain point also um it isn't
uncommon variety notes it isn't uncommon
for an athlete entertainer or celebrity
to hold a limited position in
professional sports
a-rod's former teammate Derek Jeter for
instance is part owner of baseball's
Miami Marlins the team's managing
partner is venture capitalist brute
Sherman Wild Jeter who owns about 4% of
the club runs business and baseball
operations cheater contributed about 25
million dollars to the purchase of the
team which was sold for 1.2 billion ok
so that makes sense so like you're
paying for it but then there's also like
a little sweat equity involved cuz you
can't and yes and then you have a like a
low stake well then like honestly JLo
sweat equity is worth so much like she
just needs to go to games I forgot she's
Jenny from the Bronx like the Mets are
so her their Mets are so her she like
they'll go to games
it'll be so fabulous this is really what
the Mets need like they need a win
yeah and loser team like in New York
sadly like there they are better than
the Yankees it's my understanding like
the Yankees are like chic and the Mets
are like orange okay I don't think
they're better than the Yankees are else
they would like win stuff but I just
feel like they have so much heart I feel
like there's so many or hers ourselves
included I am a Mets fan really I feel
like yeah I don't know they just have
like more heart and soul I'm asking been
who's better the Yankees or the Mets in
the last few years like I'm pretty sure
the Mets are better but like nobody
cares no but if they were better people
would care no but like they are they
like diehard fans they're like the toast
like they're kind of like thank you
present just they have diehard fans that
doesn't mean they're better than the
Yankees but I do think is like I think
like that's just what I remember hearing
from Ben we'll see these are always on
the Yankees are always in the World
Series
and that's our nothing of the sort I
don't think that's true that the Yankees
are always in the World Series they are
always in the World Series when we were
kids there was like five years back to
back where they were in the World Series
like every year but like it happened
last year they're always in the playoffs
and stuff it's like them and the Dodgers
and the Justin Verlander's Justin
Verlander's are the Houston's yeah and
they cheated they cheated they did cheat
I heard that also yeah and they got
their title taken away is that that's
like crazy and nobody was talking about
that yeah that's mad embarrassing mad
embarrassing for Kate Upton like this is
a shame a [ __ ] stain on her name
honestly no it's not like she still got
to like storm the field when it mattered
oh that's so true and then get married
right after in Tuscany like that was the
best month for her yeah everything else
is just semantics if they want to take
that trophy back now it's fine it was
taking up space in her house yeah like
she needs more space for Sports
Illustrated rookie Awards exactly
important things should we dive into our
TV recap segment where we recap the
fabulous show Outer Banks I have so many
thoughts yes okay so the show Outer
Banks if you're just listening and you
have no interest in watching is about a
group of teens I would say it's a cross
between the OC Riverdale and national
treasure
yes Claudia Ben respond as you said the
Yankees for sure are better yeah that's
what I've been trying to tell you
something the Mets the Mets have more
heart and personality and you just think
they're the underdogs and you want to
root for them and when they do win it's
gonna be like the biggest celebration
this town has ever seen right right okay
Outer Banks OC Riverdale national
treasure
um they show just like popped up onto
Netflix snitch was adamant that we watch
it she was so right it's a group of like
attractive teens but it's like um kind
of like the last song where it's like
they're all living on the same island
but then there are the people who are
the second homers and then there are the
people who there are the locals and
there's just like this rivalry
there was a lot of the rivalry that was
really intense and that was like really
scary when topper was like gonna drown
John be like are you people murderers
yeah there was a little too much
fighting for me um and I get that
there's this rivalry like it's totally
real I know that whole vibe like you
know quads verse pogs whatever they were
called but like it was a lot like with
the guns and then like the drowning it
was the hitting
when Pope was trying to deliver
groceries and they hit him with a golf
club like that was too much and he
should have sank their boat suck them
yeah [ __ ] that I just wish he hadn't
gotten caught they were so out of
control and like what the all those um
cooks were such losers and followers
like some of them are even saying like
stop stop no like make your friends stop
and by the way since when are these like
loser golf players so strong that like
John B works out on the farm he
literally is just lifts all day and he
gets his ass beat by some golf kid yeah
there was a lot of speculation as to
whether or not John B had lip fillers I
don't think so no but I do have like a
small casting problem I really really
think and I liked the show I have a lot
of actual problems with the show but I
think that the characters that were
casted for um John B and JJ is should
have been swapped no way yeah why I
honestly don't think John P was like he
was correctly cast why cuz you don't
think he is attractive enough what is it
I just think that JJ would have been a
better job a and then I have a whole
other problem we did name John B I know
like why do we have to keep saying his
initial like are there so many John's on
the island
alright at first I'm like who's the
other John because we're obviously
calling him John B for a reason and then
they just kept calling him John B and
they were not even saying John B it was
John B like I was so confused I thought
his name was CH o and B why for a second
chubby and never be like even at the
very end when Sarah's washed up on the
boat she's looking she's like jammy-jam
B it's like if you were actually
trending you would be like John yeah J
he's like me you just get the letter out
yeah
I agree with that I completely disagree
about JJ and Jambi being switch casting
I think Jambi was so good-looking and
interesting to look at like just he had
a batch that could carry it Sachi you
know like I just I thought he was great
um
JJ's character was so annoying like so
out of control like so wild and and
senseless but then you got a look at his
home life and you understood more about
him but it was just like when he's
running around with this gun like
putting everyone at risk like all the
time they have so much to lose it just
was really frustrating well that's the
other thing that I'm really glad you
brought up because part of the reason
why I really had a hard time watching
the show and I wanted to watch it
because I wanted to recap and everyone I
know like loved it I mean you and Margo
loves something and the toasters love
something I mean I love everything like
I couldn't believe I wasn't really like
pulled in by episode six by episode the
end of episode 5 is when I got to a
point where I decided I was gonna finish
it but up until then it was really give
or take
I found the episodes like so long and
the scenes like so slow and I just found
myself on my phone so much which I I
hate but what I was gonna say was oh my
biggest problem at the show was that it
was four protagonists making bad
decisions and that's really hard for me
to watch like there were so many
instances where they should have gone to
the police I know kids and TV shows like
refuse to go to the police but like the
police in that town the police weren't
corrupt like that policewoman who got
shot who was the real hero like she was
really trying to do the right thing for
sure but her partner was corrupt so what
if they had accidentally went to him I
guess but like I don't know it was just
so frustrating and then nobody
absolutely nobody in the group they
claimed that they were such good friends
like Pogues for Pogues like what all
that [ __ ] but nobody respected Pope at
all they respect the fact that he had
something really big on the line the
whole summer they were dragging him into
a life of crime forcing him to start
smoking weed and like getting in fights
when he had a real future a real future
with the merit scholarship it's a really
big deal yes I completely agree with
that I also felt like there was just way
too many like chasing scenes where they
were like running and being chased like
the whole show was just like them
running out of trouble and like just
getting away by the skin of their teeth
um and so I understood like sometimes it
was frustrating but overall I just like
loved it
love the vibe I loved all of the
characters I loved I mean I love the
friend group in general I loved Kiara
like I thought she was everything the
sort and Pope cuz like he was smart
um and then eventually did like Sarah
and John B and she just like kept doing
everything right and I can't believe
that Deacon Claybourne I mean if you're
this far into the recap like we're about
to spoil it so spoiler alert spoiler
alert spoiler alert spoiler alert that
Deacon Claybourne who plays Ward Cameron
turned out to be the bad guy like the
worst guy yeah I had thought what was
gonna happen because at first I thought
the show was setting up like the whole
season they were gonna looking for the
treasure and then at the end they found
it or they didn't find it so I thought
that when they found out that the gold
was gonna be on Tammy hill whatever that
property was called that Sarah's dad
owned I thought because they said
Sarah's dad used to be a Pope so I
thought that he became rich because he
found the buried treasure but didn't
tell anyone I'm like that's money
they've been living off of so they were
essentially searching in the right place
but there was gonna be nothing there but
then it turns out he really made his
money and then he was like still hunting
for treasure and he was like living this
life of crime but what I did like about
the show is that there was a twist like
the whole season wasn't like are they
gonna find it or they're not gonna find
it they found it on episode like five or
six but then there was the politics
around like excavating it and all that
stuff yes I would agree with that that
there was a twist and then it kind of
becomes like a whole different show like
when there's that manhunt on the island
like that was so frustrating that like
Oh anyone had to do was any time they
saw a police officer say that it was
race like the only one person heard it
once like scream it from the rooftops
that was so frustrating and that scene
on the tarmac when we find anything
justice is about to be served and then
it drags out for like three more
episodes of the most injustice ever was
very frustrating when Rafe comes and
shoots that good cop like I my heart
sank
I [ __ ] hate him dangerous he's so
insane like and I can't believe and I
feel like Ward even though he obviously
got greedy and like went nuts um for a
while you could I can make the argument
that like he wasn't he's not that bad of
a guy like he accidentally killed John
me sad then he didn't know what to do
and he was really [ __ ] stupid but
none of that was like evil yet until he
goes to like try and kill John B and
then allows his son to
coppa like he could have turned his son
in that son was a worthless piece of
[ __ ] Ward didn't even like him anyway
that son is just like so dumb and
dangerous and also powerful like when
he's riding around town with that drug
dealer who I can't stand like I just had
such a pit like to me it's worse for
them to have found jonbi than it would
be for the police
yeah but also when the drug dealer
eventually knows that Rafe killed the
cop and he's like I own you forever I'm
like yeah yes and my but like honestly I
feel like they casted the the Rich Dad
the Cameron Ward really really well
because at first like he was like this
like wholesome southern guy and he was
like taking care of everyone after the
storm and like looking for scooter like
he seemed like this really good guy and
I really didn't think up for like a few
episodes that he was at all involved
yeah me too but I think it's also
because he played Deacon Claybourne in
Nashville and also in Jesse he's a dad
like you don't think this Disney dad is
gonna be like stealing treasure yeah III
genuine I generally like think shows
about finding treasure are stupid this
one is an exception um and I also just
loved like learning about a new place
and like the new culture like like the
new um like I never heard about her
banks I got to know about the Pogues and
the coab's like I just like learning
I've never heard about it you've never
heard about her banks I guess cuz I went
to Colgate it's like a very cool Katie
place um also I was reading in the
toasters that apparently it wasn't
filmed on the actual island I'm Outer
Banks and I'm and like to me it's like
water Marsh looks I mean the scene if
you read the book where the crawdads
saying I don't know if any only one but
um the see the scenery it's kind of
similar to what I imagined in where the
crawdad sing which is a really popular
book right now this you know just
imagine the scene reminded me of any
Nicholas Sparks book I've ever I mean
movie that I've ever seen um ya know it
was really beautifully done
I loved the casts I thought they were
all such good actors and did such a good
job and I was just like so grateful to
have a season of that and I have to
thank snitch
yeah and Netflix for delivering some
content in lieu of season 2 of the
society like I guess this will do
yeah season 2 of the society isn't isn't
happening any time before quarantines
over because it's not done filming awful
did you watch anything else last night
um I started a hallmark movie and I just
like I started this book that I totally
called educated that um is really like
deep and I and then I went to Hallmark
and I was like what am i doing like it
was just it was so stupid I couldn't
even and I actually found this hallmark
movie that was like beautiful farm
Shemin camp it was like a movie about
this like glamping Grounds and like they
would show that this doesn't like oh my
god just like a wave of relief would
wash over me and then they would like to
go to the dialog and I was like I
absolutely can't do this I feel like
those are your two personalities like
dumb Hallmark and like serious intellect
literature I know but it was just like I
couldn't like I've been spending too
much time in the serious intellect or
that I legit couldn't watch this
hallmark movie or maybe it's just like
it didn't have that that big love there
that I needed maybe um well I didn't
want anything else I'm planning on
watching too hot to handle which is the
new Netflix dating show like I think
it's supposed to be the next love is
blind people are talking about it and I
have nothing else to do so when I film
my vlog today I have a lot of stuff to
do and then I'm gonna end up probably
watching that at night okay maybe I'll
watch out that I actually got the
trailer for it and looks like something
I would watch yeah like dumb TV which is
all all we can really ask for right now
Todai oh and there was a new episode of
song land last night that I didn't watch
but I have it on my Hulu
I'm so excited I'm definitely watch out
today but I'm gonna watch it with
husband so we have to sync up our
schedules oh that's nice I'll wait for
my husband to okay cool well I think
that's all she wrote I do believe that
is she all the cheer out like I spoke
turned she said yeah I'm done right
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning toast the Millennial morning
show where we go live Monday through
Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on
YouTube so if you're watching us on
YouTube please subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as podcasts anywhere podcasts can be
found so that's Spotify iTunes stitcher
public video I have any cast box all the
places where ever you listen to podcasts
find us the morning totally a five-star
view have that have beautiful stunning
and smart we are
please also follow us on Instagram at
the morning toast for premium content we
hope you have a wonderful day we'll be
recapping dinner from pearls tomorrow
and doing our dear toaster segment so
please email us do
toaster said gmail.com if you're looking
for any advice we always keep it
anonymous have an amazing day and we
will see you tomorrow morning
I